in a serious country people deal with
issues of justice of law of order
there's a story just comes out in new
orleans a group of teens with a criminal
record just stole the car of a 73 year
old grandmother and drove it off while
she was still attached this is a little
bit gory obviously we're in a there's
video of this sort of thing
which thankfully has been blurred but as
they steal the car the woman falls out
of the car her arm is ripped off and
then she dies 73 year old grandmother
because these criminal teens were not
dealt with by the criminal justice
system and so they were free to wander
around and and then they killed this
this woman
the superintendent of police in new
orleans sean ferguson describes
the incident ferguson did say he wants
the teens charged as adults brazenness
broad daylight
with no regards to this woman
hanging from the vehicle so i mean i
think at some point in time we have to
step up and say we're going to hold
individuals accountable yes sean
ferguson the new orleans police
department they got it right we've got
to hold people accountable these kids
should not have been allowed back on the
street they had this criminal record
they
you're seeing this not just in new
orleans not just with teens but with
everyone there's a movement to let
criminals off the hook and it's being
pushed explicitly by democrats who
explicitly want to defund the police who
want to abolish police departments who
want to abolish federal prisons there's
congressional democrats very prominent
ones who are trying to abolish prisons
entirely at the federal level
now this police officer says this is bad
we got to hold people accountable but
the poor woman who was killed here
her boss was asked what
what he thought about the incident what
he thought should happen to the kids and
obviously he agrees with the police
officer that they should be punished he
just doesn't have any faith in the
system i have virtually no confidence in
the system right now
does anybody you know i would love to
see him be prosecuted as adults
send a message not only to
somebody who would be thinking about
doing that but this you know what is the
purpose in it what purpose was this it's
a senseless murder
he has no faith in the system nor do we
nor do we because crime is not punished
because criminals are let off the hook
criminals have been recast by democrats
as the real victims and the victims are
somehow the perpetrators of the crime
because of society those poor teens
they've been failed by society it's not
their fault
but of course it is their fault they
made a decision even even teenagers can
make decisions sometimes even teenagers
have to be held accountable or at least
rehabilitated but no we live in a in a
country where up is down and left is
right and right is wrong and true is
false we live in this country where the
elites the ruling elites have upended
everything where now the best woman
swimmer
is a man right where the criminals are
the victims where everything is upside
down and the elites don't need to deal
with the consequences of that
this is the key this is how it's allowed
to go on
because if the if the elites if the
people who were setting the society
people making the laws the people
forming the culture in hollywood the
people
deciding what information gets out there
through big technology through the media
if those people had to deal with crime
on the street like that 73 year old
grandma were
mark my words those teens would be
rotting away in prison for life
at best
that would be that would be the luckiest
case scenario for the teens okay
if
the elites were dealing with crime
throughout our cities
there wouldn't be crime for very long
they wouldn't be talking about
abolishing the police or defunding the
police they would be privately funding
police departments and jails to
incarcerate these people forever
i'm so glad you like that clip now ring
the bell subscribe make sure you get the
notifications and also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review if
you haven't watched it yet you've got to
watch fouchy unmasked the three-part
docu-series at dailywire.com we'll see
you there
[Music]
[Music]
you